>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO OUR FREE
AND FAIR ELECTIONS AND OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS AN ONGOING
THREAT TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT BETRAYED OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND BETRAYED
THE SECURITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
>> DONALD TRUMP REMAINS AND HAS
BEEN A THREAT TO AMERICA'S
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> NUMEROUS CRIMES THREATENING
THE NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THREATS AGAINST OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY THAT WE CANNOT DEFEND
OR DISMISS.
>> HE UNDERMINED OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> AND COMPROMISED SO YOU CAN
KEEP POWER.
>> WE MUST ACT WITHOUT DELAY.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT DELAY!
OF COURSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE DELAYS WERE OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
IMPEACHMENT SEEMED TO HURT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ONE THING, IT DROVE REASONABLE
PEOPLE OUT OF THE PARTY.
ONE OF THESE IS CONGRESSMAN
SCOTT VAN DREW OF SOUTH JERSEY
FOR THIS IMPEACHMENT DEBACLE AND
IT HAS BEEN FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CONVINCE YOU TO LEAVE YOUR
PARTY.
>> IT WAS PART OF IT.
CERTAINLY WAS PART OF IT.
EVEN THE MOST BIZARRE BEHAVIOR
OCCURRING RIGHT NOW, SO
IMPORTANT THAT IT BE TIMELY, HAD
TO DO IT FOR THE SAFETY AND GOOD
OF THE COUNTRY.
I VOTED NO, AS YOU KNOW, I
DIDN'T VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE IT
WAS A WEEK IMPEACHMENT.
IT WASN'T IN MY OPINION AN
ACCURATE IMPEACHMENT AND I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD'VE BEEN DONE AND
IT HARMED THE COUNTRY, SPLIT US
APART, IT REALLY HURT THE VERY
ESSENCE OF THIS NATION I THINK
IN MANY WAYS.
BUT THEY DID IT.
SO WE FINALLY DID IT AND NOW THE
NECESSARY PAPERWORK, THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT, HAVE
NOT BEEN TRANSFERRED OVER.
>> YOU DIDN'T GO ALONG WITH
THAT!
>> THEY KNEW I WASN'T BECAUSE I
WAS VERY UPFRONT WITH FOLKS LIKE
YOU AND EVERYONE I COULD TALK TO
AND REALLY SPOKE TO EVEN SOME OF
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WERE MORE
MODERATE ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE,
MORE CONSERVATIVE.
WE HAD THE BLUE DOG AT EVERYBODY
DECIDING THEY WOULD GO ALONG.
I WAS VERY SURPRISED BECAUSE IN
ESSENCE I THAT THEY WOULD STOP
IT.
THAT ALONG OTHER THINGS I'VE
BELIEVED OVER THE YEARS ABOUT
AMERICA AND THE DIRECTION THAT
AMERICA SHOULD TAKE WHETHER THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT A SEGMENT ON
STRONG BORDERS, HOW WE NEED TO
HAVE STRONG BORDERS OF WAS GOING
ON IN MEXICO.
I JUST THINK WE ARE GOING THE
OTHER DIRECTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING THE WRONG
DIRECTION.
THEY ARE NOT THE OLD BLUE DOGS I
REMEMBER OF YEARS AGO SO I
REALLY CAME TO THE POINT -- IT
ALL JUST CAME TOGETHER.
IT WAS AN AMAZING SITUATION
WHERE I HEARD FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND AT THE SAME
TIME -- BY THE WAY, THIS IS
AFTER I ALREADY VOTED MY WAY.
I DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY QUESTION
THAT IF YOU HELP US VOTE A
CERTAIN WAY WITH IMPEACHMENT CAN
WILL HELP YOU IF YOU WANT TO
CHANGE PARTIES.
NEVER, EVER.
ALL IT WAS IS IT ALL CAME
TOGETHER.
I FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE AS A
REPUBLICAN, I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
MORE CONSERVATIVE.
FRANKLY I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN
LIBERATED.
>> Tucker: HOW HAVE DEMOCRATS
IN YOUR STATE AND IN WASHINGTON
TREAT YOU?
>> THERE ARE SOME THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN NICE OR DON'T TALK TO YOU.
SOME THAT WON'T SPEAK WITH YOU
AT ALL.
I'VE HAD SOME AMAZING REACTIONS
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE EVEN
OUR INDEPENDENCE OR UNDECLARED
OR DEMOCRATS, WAS NOT ONLY THE
PRINCIPAL OF WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
SOMETHING I DISAGREE WITH.
IT'S THE IDEA THAT I WAS TOLD IN
SPEAKING TO YOU ABOUT THIS
BEFORE IN COUNTIES.
ONE OF THE COUNTIES, ONE OF THE
CHAIRMAN SAID TO ME, YOU ARE
VOTING FOR IMPEACHMENT.
I NEVER HAD THAT BEFORE, SOMEONE
SPOKE TO ME.
YOU ARE GOING TO VOTE AND YOU
PROBABLY WILL GET TO RODDEN IN
THIS COUNTY.
I SAID THE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I WALKED AWAY AND THOUGHT ABOUT
IT AND EVERYTHING COME TOGETHER
MY MIND.
TALK ABOUT QUID PRO QUO!
>> Tucker: I'M GLAD THAT
DIDN'T WORK.
>> IT DIDN'T WORK.
IT'S SUCH A WRONG THING TO DO
AND THAT'S WHY SOME PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T THAT POLITICAL HAVE BEEN
SO AMAZINGLY SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE
IT TOOK THAT'S WHAT YOU DID AND
DID THE RIGHT THING.
>> Tucker: DON'T CAVE TO THE
THUGS.
THAT'S THE LESSON.
>> THINGS FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
I ENJOYED IT.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: GOLDEN GLOBES HOST
RICKY GERVAIS WENT AGAINST
HOLLYWOOD CALLING AT THEIR
HYPOCRISY.
MARK STEYN WAS THERE, DON'T MISS